so i have multiple stories today about
slurs and epithets it wasn't just
donald trump accused of it and we will
look at that shortly it was also
donald trump's friend roger stone doing
it on live radio calling a black man
negro during an interview remember that
just days ago
donald trump commuted the prison
sentence of roger stone
and it was another one of these powerful
and defiant shows of cronyism and
corruption from donald trump
and incredibly just days after having
his sentence commuted by donald trump
uh roger stone calls into the mr mo
kelly show on los angeles radio
station kfi 640 am and they're debating
stone's conviction and at one point
stone goes quiet and then you hear him
say
i don't really feel like arguing with
this negro check it out the line then
goes dead but it's really not dead
roger stone is just sitting there not
saying anything and then he eventually
comes back and says no i didn't i didn't
say i didn't call you a negro take a
listen to this
i don't know that's my argument no no i
do believe that
certain people are treated differently
in the federal justice system i do
absolutely believe that but i also
believe that your friendship
and relationship and history with donald
trump weighed more heavily
than him just wanted to make sure that
justice was done by
a person in the justice system that you
were treated so unfairly there are
thousands of people treated unfairly
daily how your number just happened to
come up in the lottery
i'm guessing it was more than just luck
roger
right
i don't really feel like arguing with
this
i'm sorry what was that
roger
roger
i'm sorry what did you say
i'm sorry you're arguing with him
i thought we were having just a very
spirited conversation what happened
would you not like to continue the
conversation sir
i hear that the line is not dead
uh you're back i don't know what that
was
there yeah i was i was talking and you
said something about negro so i wasn't
exactly sure
i did not oh okay you're out of your
mind
i don't hear your mind okay well
we'll let the listeners decide let me go
to the next question then
why whatever and roger stone just
sticking with that explanation just
insisting he never said it stone again
denied
making the comment in a statement given
to the christian broadcasting network
yeah it's as funny as it sounds claiming
that there was crosstalk and it made it
difficult to know who said what which of
course
is not the case it is perfectly silent
at the time that he says it and you hear
the phrase very very clearly
and the word negro even more clearly
take a look i don't really feel like
arguing
i'm sorry what was that there must have
been uh gremlins in the phone line or a
hacker
or someone who right when roger stone
went quiet
was able to intercept the phone call and
insert the word negro
into the communication right would that
maybe be a more believable explanation
and when i listened back to it the most
obvious part about it for me is
if the phone really broke up and roger
stone couldn't hear anything for a while
and hadn't
called the host a negro he would have
been really confused and flummoxed and
outraged by the accusation that he said
negro he just immediately denies saying
it like
if i was being interviewed and for 30
seconds i couldn't hear anything
and then when i can hear the host again
the coast says
you just said something about a negro i
would say what what on earth are you
talking about i've said nothing for 30
seconds
i've never called the black person a
negro and i have no clue what you're
talking about
stone's reaction is to say no i didn't i
didn't call you a negro
it's almost orwellian like you can't
trust what you hear
and then you know pretending the line
was seemingly dead when it wasn't
there's just not that much more to say
here this is exactly the type of people
that trump has around him
it's a pretty simple analysis not
everybody who supports trump is racist
obviously but the racists overwhelmingly
support
trump and he has many of them around him
and that's sort of it you know i i don't
want to be arguing with a negro that
it's their plane as day
this is clearly how roger stone grew up
referring to black people sometimes
people are just racist
you know there are times for more
precision are we
is this an instance of prejudice or are
we talking about systemic versus
personal racism or is someone
insensitive or whatever
this is just a racist guy who says
racist things and he got caught and
that's it it's very much in line with
the trump administration technique of
sometimes they do something crazy and
then they just denied that it happened
trump said 15 cases would go to zero oh
well you know fouchy at one point said
don't wear a mask
then that's okay then they just move on
and they go to the next thing
this is the guy that roger stone
commuted
uh the sentence for just a few days ago
and immediately out there arguing with
radio hosts and referring to them as
negroes that's what it is
now we'll go from stone to trump if you
love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video